I saw you instagrammed about it Kobe how
did you hear what was your reaction how
are you feeling right now God I mean I
don't know how to put it I I thought it
was fake because how can you not it
really makes you think about how a lot
of things I don't know it's really hard
to talk about it's so sudden and so
random and like his beautiful girl and
like I I have no words my condolences
I don't know what to say on Sunday
basketball legend Kobe Bryant died after
his private helicopter crashed around
the LA neighborhood of Calabasas his 13
year old daughter Gianna was also on
board the helicopter ET spoke with stars
on the Grammys red carpet about the
shocking news is extremely unexpected
and sad and like you know Kobe goes
beyond just basketball and he's like an
icon a legend overall while others paid
tribute on social media Drake shared
this snap on Instagram writing it can't
be Khloe Kardashian tweeted this can't
be real there's no way my heart hurts
meanwhile Kanye West wrote Kobe we love
you brother were praying for your family
and appreciate the life you've lived and
all the inspiration you gave Chrissy
Teigan tweeted I cannot believe this is
real and Dwyane Wade echoed her
disbelief writing no God please no it's
very difficult for me to put in words
how I feel about the loss of Kobe Bryant
Kareem abdul-jabbar shared an emotional
video on Twitter
rest in peace young man this loss is
it's just hard to comprehend
/ God Michael Jordan released a
statement saying that he was in shock
adding that he loved Kobe like a little
brother quote words can't describe the
pain I'm feeling demi lovato shared her
condolences on Instagram posting this
pic with the former NBA pro writing in
part quote Kobe you were always so sweet
to me you are a legend with wings now
Haley Bieber explained that she is
devastated to the core while her husband
Justin Bieber shared this throwback pic
with Kobe writing that the athlete
always encouraged him you know he always
showed me love and it was always jr. you
know I was a fan of his game you know
she's real unfortunately Kris Jenner
shared her deepest love and prayers on
Instagram Kylie Jenner said she was at a
loss for words Taylor Swift tweeted that
her heart is in pieces Bella Hadid said
she can't believe the tragic news while
Julia Roberts captioned a pic of Kobe on
Instagram with a simple broken heart
emoji Kevin Hart also expressed his
grief on Instagram with two posts one
with the caption this honestly doesn't
make sense I just saw you man
this hurts my heart and Camilla Kibeho
shared a lengthy post on Instagram
calling Kobe a hero and explaining that
quote his words and way of thinking and
living that lifted me up during times
where I felt like I couldn't get off the
ground
you